the problem is not the parents the
problem is not the children the problem
is a system that protects academic
failure hi I'm Nicolas b4 recent TV and
today we're talking with Madeleine
Sackler the director of the lottery a
new documentary about school choice
thanks for coming thank you tell us what
is the lottery that you're talking about
in the lottery
well the lottery in this case is
actually for a school it's a
high-performing school in Harlem it's a
public charter school and by love more
parents enter their kids to attend the
school than theirs space they have to
hold a lottery and that's exactly what
it is and I mean this is where a kid's
hopes are either you know make whole or
totally crushed right yeah I mean
parents in Harlem are very lucky because
they have a lot of options for their
kids unfortunately a lot of parents
still don't know about all of their
choices so some of the parents in the
film this was the only school that they
had applied to and their chances were
not good and these are always described
I mean those scenes as gut wrenching and
tear-jerking and whatnot what what drew
you to the material I had actually I had
seen I didn't know much about charter
schools or really the sort of reforms
that were happening in public education
and then I saw news footage of the
lottery that we ended up featuring in
2008 and I was really surprised by the
number of parents that were there
there's about 5,000 parents for how many
slots about 400 and I just couldn't
believe it because I had been hearing
that the reasons for the achievement gap
and the problems of public education
were be cut where poverty poverty based
our culture based or because certain
parents don't value education and yet
what I saw was totally contradictory to
that I literally saw thousands of
parents that wanted something better so
I wanted to tell their side of the story
what is it about charter schools that
make parents come out in droves to you
know to get their kids in them I think
parents respond to results and and they
respond to the culture in the schools
they can see that they're strict but
focused on positive reinforcement and
towards getting the kids to college
so you know it's very striking like the
school that we featured in the film
about 95% of their kids are at grade
level and in Harlem overall it's 56
percent which is hard to understand but
the fact that there's really half of
students in Harlem overall or at grade
level
that's an enormous difference I mean
they're basically achieving twice who
are the villains in the lottery well I
don't know if there's really villains I
mean I think it's easy to point fingers
but but what I did point some well I
mean what I what I discovered by the end
of the project was that the answer to my
question going in which was you know if
there's all these parents that want
better schools and there are schools
that are closing the achievement gap why
aren't there more and the answer is
politics and there are organizations
like the teachers union and acorn and
certain politicians that are very
committed to the status quo do you think
that we're at a tipping point I mean one
of the things that's interesting is that
school choice is about choice we have
choice and increasing amounts of choice
in other parts of our lives whether it's
you know coffee drinks or supermarkets
or clothing are we on the verge of an
educational revolution that is based on
consumer choice yeah I absolutely
believe that this is a critical point
right now I mean it's really historic I
think it will go down in history and I
just hope that we continue moving in
this direction because the president is
taking President Obama is taking
extraordinary measures to try to
implement critical school reform well
his race to the top efforts are you know
over four billion dollars towards real
school reform although he also shut down
the school choice program in DC yes
that's true yeah I think the his
commitment may be questioned but there
is - the top thing I mean the race to
the top effort we're seeing reform
sweeping the country I mean in New York
in January the cap on charter schools
was at 200 and they weren't able to lift
it but now in June at the and just in
time for the second race to the top
deadline they more than doubled it and
that's a real real change for kids so I
think you know your local politician
cares what
think about education reform and
politics in general so if you see them
in the supermarket ask them why there's
an achievement gap and what they're
doing to fix it you know calling them
leaving messages if they get 50 or 100
letters it makes a huge difference why
should somebody who doesn't have
school-age children or doesn't
particularly care about education be
interested in your movie well this is
definitely something that affects all of
us I mean I think whether or not you
have children the risk of failing to
improve public education is enormous not
only on a financial level but Mayor Cory
Booker calls this the biggest threat to
our national security because we will
just not be able to continue to compete
on a global level other reasons to care
about the movie I think it's a really
good story about we talked about one of
the characters who you find most
memorable and what is their journey
through the picture I mean for me the
most interesting and important thing
about this film and the issue really are
the kids and the families and we
featured four really beautiful families
who are just when I when you look really
drill into it this is just a story about
parents that want something for their
kids and can't have it and the obstacles
that stand in their way and I think
that's really a just a universal story
what are the types of things that
charter schools do or schools of choice
more broadly what are they doing
differently that you don't see in a
traditional school yeah I mean I think
it's very odd to me that there's sort of
this attachment to a one-size-fits-all
approach to education I mean there's
kids are all really different and
parents more affluent parents forever
have had the ability to send their kids
to schools that focus more on art or on
sports or math and science and that's
just been sort of an elitist opportunity
and in the country and yet people point
to public education as the foundation of
our democracy well I don't think that
our democracy is about serving kids in
certain demographics in lower-income
communities a worse education
higher income communities I don't know
where you fell that's you know that's
the Marxist rating of American society
which is that the the school system
exists to replicate the existing class
order right yeah well I don't think that
that's very good or for the country or
for commute like certain communities so
I think if we you know look really
deeply at what matters to kids and to
each of us we'd realize that it's right
and and just to provide families and
lower-income communities with the same
choices that other to you how do you
describe yourself politically I I think
I'm a political and it's funny because
the movies been called partisan and it's
really that I mean it's that's just
factually wrong but it's also just not a
partisan issue I mean we show in the
film very clearly Democrats on both
sides of the gradient so I don't really
think that I fall on one side or another
to me it's just very simples we should
be doing what's best for kids and that's
not in any way a political statement how
did you feel in you know in those
moments when you're you're filming
children and families who are either
elated or absolutely dejected I mean how
as a filmmaker how do you how do you
process that well it's really hard going
into it because everyone from us to the
families are placing a bet I mean we're
playing odds and the the chance of each
of the four kids in the film winning the
lottery was one in seven that's terrible
odds and so you know all of us I think
were emotionally preparing ourselves for
either outcome for all of the kids but
there's just no real way to prepare
yourself for something like that I mean
I think the risks are enormous for the
kids and the pot the possible upswing is
you know even greater but you know we
became very close to the families so
we're we're still in touch so it's not
like everything ended on at the lottery
I want to thank Madeleine Sackler
director of
lottery a new documentary about school
choice for talking to reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie